[Music]
garrett is in las vegas hi garrett
welcome to the ramsay show
hi ken hi dave thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up
hey so my question is
where do unexpected home repairs fall
into baby step two
emergencies
okay so let's say that the emergency
fund is it an
emergency
um
i'd probably say it's not an emergency
then you don't do it in baby step two
got it so we wouldn't treat it
like a
an emergency if it's not
okay because uh basically
um it we it's a bathroom and our kitchen
kind of got shut down because of a leak
we gotta fix the leak
well the league is fixed but the
insurance didn't cover the cost of the
total repair so essentially we're just
down the bathroom now so i was just like
essentially they said it's going to be
seven thousand dollars to fix the rest
of the bathroom
i'm sorry stop stop stop stop stop stop
the toilet repair cost seven thousand
dollars
no the bathroom it's the whole bathroom
okay what's wrong with the bathroom
so um we had a
leak that went unnoticed
for about six months uh murphy's law we
bought our house last year
and uh we didn't notice it was coming
from our master bathroom into the
kitchen and it basically we noticed it
when the floors were essentially
potentially
starting to you know
cave in a little bit
and
obviously with mold remediation
repair
pretty much the insurance only covered
to a certain amount so it covered like
the cost of the kitchen and the
demolition of the bathroom but pretty
much like
almost all the walls are like down in
the bathroom and then no shower
and pretty much the whole thing is
you know gonna cost
seven thousand dollars so i didn't know
if we would save
something
no
pay for that before you need it you
gotta classify this need whether this is
an emergency or whether it isn't so i
don't understand why the insurance
didn't cover the entire repair
uh because
the limit on the um hidden water leak oh
only a 10 000 yeah
okay that makes sense
all right so um
how many bathrooms do you have
uh well it's a three bed two bath and so
you have one bath operating
correct and you have how many people
two you and your wife
yes
okay
and what's your household income
uh we met 110. and what's your debt that
you have remaining
uh 69 000.
okay it's gonna take you two years
okay
to get out that right
yes
roughly i mean 18 months to two years if
you're really hardcore on this it
shouldn't take you longer than two years
um
okay uh
the way i try to answer questions on the
show is what would i do if i woke up in
your shoes
okay what do you owe the 69 000 on
well
31 000
roughly spread over
two cars
28 000 in credit card and about 10 000
student loans
and what is the most expensive car
the most expensive car
oh okay um so the most expensive car is
going to be like my off-roading flash
overlanded vehicle and that uh that's
like
19 000.
okay
all right um
would you trade that for a bathroom
absolutely
would
really
absolutely would
because i might not
okay anyway here's the way i answer
questions what would i do if i woke up
in your shoes you have a bathroom it's
just the two of you this is an adventure
let the stupid thing sit and get
yourself out of debt that's what sharon
and i would do if we woke up in your
shoes now if i wanted to get out of that
a little bit faster because the bathroom
um is a big deal the second bathroom
uh when we have one couple living in the
house um i mean i want you to get the
stupid thing fixed obviously but it you
know if you want to speed it up the way
you speed it up is you start selling off
the expensive cars
and that speeds up how fast you get out
of that right
yes because one third of your debt or
one-fourth of your debt is one car
that's true and boom you know we just
cut down your two years to uh
you know a year and maybe 14 months or
something like that
and you can knock the rest of this out
if you want to now really what that buys
you is um almost a year of fighting this
stuff and waiting on to fix your seven
thousand dollar bath but no i would not
budget in a
non-emergency non-leaking you do have
indoor plumbing you have a bath
sounds like a little creepy of a
situation but i'm with you our roof was
leaking when we were broke
and we decided we were going to live
this way
i got some of that black tar stuff in a
5 5-gallon bucket and smeared it around
on the roof and stopped the water from
running down the light fixture onto the
kitchen table
it looked like crap but i could not
afford a 6 000 roof at the time and
that's what it took to put a roof on
that house
and uh we lived like that for two years
while we got out of debt and after we
got out of debt i put a new roof on the
house with cash because i don't borrow
money anymore and i wasn't gonna stop
getting out of debt for that one place
that it was leaking and couldn't figure
it out a cheap way to do it so i just
made a mess yeah i completely agree a
couple one couple no kids one fully
functioning bathroom take care of your
priorities it's not that big of a deal
it's a great story to tell anyway you
know all your friends and family already
know about it anyway because of the
ordeal you've been through yeah and you
kind of you know
someday when you have kids you can go
you know back in our 22 we lived with
one bathroom yeah
you know you tell the grandkids that
right what'd you call that stuff put on
the roof what was that black what was it
yeah because whatever you call it well
no the reason i said it because i
recently had i recently had a leak in my
roof which you know about and i just
didn't have time to get anybody out
there and so i waited until it stopped
raining i got that flex seal from that
awful infomercial that guy screams at
you about putting his boat back together
why didn't you just throw your shamwow
up there
so i went up with the flex seal sprayed
it stopped the leak until the roofers
get to get out there really well now
we've got an endorsement for flex seal i
didn't mean an unpaid endorsement i
didn't mean to do that unpaid
endorsement but i mean you know where
there's a will there's no i mean this
was you're in a different century than i
was when i did this i love that though
i love it 1988's a different world
22. can you even get tar for your house
these days
no
i doubt it i don't even know how that
stuff works it's just that it's like
like dry it's
nasty yeah it's nasty i love it it's a
great pretty much pretty much white
trash
what i was doing